Long before any birds were angry or candy was crushed,...
...Tetris was among the first habit-forming puzzle games.
But a new study in the journal Appetite suggests the classic block game...
...could actually break some of your other habits.
The theory of elaborated intrusion holds that our cravings...
...come from visual cues that pop into our heads.
So, researchers at Plymouth University decided to test if other visual stimulus,...
...like a heavy game of Tetris, could help curb our desire...
...for a drink, cigarette or an unhealthy snack.
After two groups of volunteers reported similar cravings,...
...they had one group play the game...
...while the other sat with a screen that never finished loading.
Afterward, the participants who had actually played Tetris for at least three minutes...
...reported as much as 24% fewer cravings,...
...suggesting the game helped keep out those unwanted visuals.